if you leak the age of a person you also leak their birthday their full date of birth right
because what you can do is you can just look at that age and then find the day that it changes
and then you've got the person's birthday
all right y'all we've talked about threat locker ring fencing a lot we know how it allows you to
set acls and policies for exactly what an application is allowed to do in your network
but today i'm going to tell you how it does that okay three technologies many filter drivers
window filtering platform and ex version kernel notification routines many filter drivers are
essentially a hook or callback for um io requests okay so when you're trying to write or read from a
file you can create a hook with those and improve or deny based off of the threat locker acl windows
filtering platform similar situation but for connect bind uh requests right you can say okay
hey is this process allowed to talk to port 443 over there on the internet yes or no approve or deny
lastly you've got ex version kernel notification routines the ex version is important because
it allows you to approve or deny versus just getting a notification from the kernel
and this is specific for um hooking various native api calls like nt create user process which is what
you would use to like spin up powershell.exe or something like that okay so those three are very
useful to threat lockers ring fencing core technology hope you enjoyed learning how this is implemented
check out threat locker if you think your work could benefit from something like that all right let's
go back to the show all right sup hackers before we jump into the episode this week i got a couple quick
announcements in the this week in bug bounty section the first one is actually the first three are from
yes we hack uh yes we hack has dropped another complete guide uh and it's this time it's on os command
injection um as i was reading through this there's a bunch of really good summaries on what kind of
techniques to use here you can see a bunch of payloads where the um you know command will break
out of various different contexts one of the things i've learned about command injection is you will
only find it if you're looking for it right um and i i know a couple hackers franz and matias that often
find these bugs and the reason they often find them is they are often spraying payloads just like these
uh polyglots that include multiple contexts or these specific ones that are right here um so grab some
of these integrate this into your testing workflow and some of these command injections will fall out i've
i've seen it happen and it's amazed me all right y'all next up is another piece from uh yes we hack this
time we're covering a critical auth bypass in wordpress azure adsso plugin man i i'm not gonna lie
guys i've had to say that i've had to do like three different takes because i can't say that um but yeah
guys this one's pretty gnarly essentially um this allowed unauthenticated attackers to log in as arbitrary
wordpress users if they're using this plugin so uh this is essentially like an rce right because if
you can log in as any wordpress user log as an admin upload some php code and then you've got uh you
can shell the server so really bad probe for this uh wordpress plugin any of you recon boys out there
um the details uh are laid out pretty cleanly here by yes we hack in the write-up um down in the proof of
concept section essentially um you can just provide a jwt token uh an id token specifically uh that just
says you are anybody right and you can just look you can just submit blah dot base64 encoded uh id
token dot blah right and it's just not checking the anything besides that middle piece of the jwt um so
that's really bad uh so definitely go ahead and poke at this if you haven't already great write-up by
yes we hack we'll link it in the description all right our last piece from yes we hack today is actually
highlighting our boy i2glow who is a part of the ctpb team and writes our hacker notes so shout out to him
those have been great lately um and this is just a bio on him so if you want to get to know i2glow better
he's an excellent hacker um and this is a good way for you to understand how he thinks how he chooses
his targets what his favorite hacking tools are um that sort of thing so uh we'll link that down in
the description as well highlighting our boy i2glow i got to get him on the pod sometimes too he'd be
he'd be a great um addition all right the last and perhaps most exciting news item that we have for
today is adobe is partnering with echo party miami may 21st and may 22nd at the echo party event to do
a live hacking event um to join the live hacking event you can submit all findings through the normal
adobe bug bounty program in scope is adobe stock lightroom web adobe workfront and they're increasing
bounties from tier one to tier three uh for the ai bonus tier here for this live hack game so if you're
going to be at echo party and want to participate in this definitely find the adobe team and we'll link
more information in the description below all right i think that's it let's jump to the main show
all right what's up hackers uh i am finally back at home after a marathon run of live hacking events
um so shout out to hacker one and google for um their various live hacking events they've been running
i've been working long hours and i've been traveling so i'm not gonna lie i'm pretty wiped um last episode
joseph and i were in korea we kind of very sleepily at at like midnight gave you guys some of the
takeaways from that event um i proceeded to spend a couple days in korea um traveling around spending
time with my wife and then came back to the us and have been hit with an absolute one two punch of
seasonal allergies here in virginia just a shit ton of pollen um and jet lag which has been quite the
combo and solo parenting while my wife went over to japan for a couple days to see some friends so um
yeah been a busy busy week um that being said this episode is going to be pretty tight as well
um my apologies for that but i do have some really interesting content so um yeah i hope you guys get
as much out of it as i did when i was finding these things uh it's definitely some good some good
takeaways so let's go ahead and take a look at those we're going to do a couple bugs and then we're going
to do a couple like just takeaways um so first up is a protobuf based xss so i wanted to tell you guys
about this because i've been hacking on a target that uses protobuf a lot um and i recently found an xss that
um requires you to actually send raw protobuf so binary level protobuf not like proto json or like
base64 encoded uh proto protobuf uh over over the wire in an http request for it to work okay and this
presents a couple challenges and i'll try to enumerate those here um anyway so like if you could send the
request then it would result in xss so it needs to be like a top level navigation in the browser right
it's not checking the content type so we can send it with text plain um i thought it was not going to
be as hard as it was but it was pretty tricky so let me tell you a couple reasons why one um there's
this thing called a dom string mutation that seems to happen whenever uh you actually add these uh this
raw binary to the dom so sometimes some of the payloads will get a bit mangled so you really have to
make sure your payload is largely within the uh pure ascii range which is um ox01 to ox7f
otherwise you're gonna it's gonna cause some problems uh within get mangled so i kind of tweaked the
payload a lot to fit that range by um you know inflating or deflating uh you know the size of various
payloads trying to shift uh types as much as i could or omit fields that were going to cause problems if
they weren't actually strictly required in the um in the protobuf payload there was some flexibility there
which was cool um so after a lot of smithing i got it into that pure ascii range um the another problem
is that if you have an lf uh a line feed um character which is ox zero a um then and it is not immediately
uh you know preceded by a uh a ox od a um cr a carriage return field then the browser is going to try to
fix that for you and uh put put in one uh which is very annoying and will break your whole payload
um so the way that i kind of got around this oh and the uh protobuf i'm looking at my notes down here
that's why i keep glancing down but the protobuf field for um you know field number one and wire type
two which is a string is going to be oa so you're not going to get away from using getting an oa in your
actual protobuf payload so the way that i actually got around this was um by buffering it up with a
a junk field before that ended in od uh and so now i've got what appears to be a um uh a real crlf
right in od oa um in the hex and then the browser doesn't feel like it needs to fix that invalid um
new line sequence there uh and it was not mingling my my protobuf payload so that was awesome um
obviously this is really tricky because protobuf is a length based thing right so if you're if your
lengths are off or if there's a stray bite in there somewhere and the the browser does anything funky
then uh your payload is going to completely break so um that was one of the issues that i ran into
and got got through the other one was uh you kind of need to send a or at least the way that i was
doing it i think there are other ways to do it but you need to send a um uh
equals character in your your payload body um if you're even if you're doing a text plane submission
uh form submission to get the top level navigation um so you need somewhere in there there's going to
be a equals sign right and something's going to be the the the key on one side and the value on the
other side and the equal in the middle right so uh how i ended up solving this one was i padded out a field
um you know that had the um the ox 3d character as the length right where i needed it to be um so that
it wouldn't heck up the the string before or the string after um with some of these weird rules for
keys versus values um in a form submission so just had to align that properly to get it to not break um and
get most of the values in the um or most of the data in the value which is a little bit less liberally
um tweaked by the uh by the browser um so we have a lot more flexibility there um
so that was another challenge was getting that um equal sign in there and then the last challenge
was really interesting which is the browser will actually append a um crlf sequence at the end of
your submission whenever you send a form which was really annoying to me i'm like okay well that might
just do me in because i need my whole you know protobuf payload needs to end with crlf um but actually
the way i solved this in the end was define a string field at the end with a length that is two
bytes longer than the length i actually provided it so when so when the browser actually appends the two
uh characters at the end that will get slurped up into the defined string at the last you know field
of the protobuf and it will actually not mess with the the byte offsets or um not parse it as extraneous
data or anything it'll just parse it as a part of the string that we already defined so let's say i
the last you know um character or the last string that i defined was four uh bytes long i would only
give it two bytes so when the browser filled in those other two bytes it would be that full four
byte string um so anyway just a interesting little um solution there if you're ever dealing with protobuf
uh that you actually need to send over the wire in um an actual like top level navigation via a form
um to trigger an xss or otherwise then those are some tips and tricks that i had along the way um all
right let's let's keep moving um up next was this was one that is not actually that crazy but i like
the mentality so i wanted to tell you guys about this so um i found a way on a program recently to
leak the age of a person excuse me of a person um and the age of the person is an interesting thing to
leak sure it has some impact on itself but as i was sitting there thinking about it if you leak the age
of a person you also leak their birthday their full date of birth right because what you can do is you
can just look at that age and then find the day that it changes and then you've got the person's birthday
right um and the full date of birth which is a lot more helpful in my opinion um obviously you could
do some brute forcing and stuff like that but if we're talking about like pii disclosure getting the
actual month and day as well as the year is valuable um so i just wanted to you know throw that out there
for y'all as thinking about whenever you're leaking some data try to think about how that data can
change over time and if that can give you any additional information uh and you might be able to
find some additional impact for your bugs um okay uh just a couple more takeaways and then i gotta wrap
this episode um cspt's work not only on web apps but also on desktop apps or any other type of app
i was hacking on a desktop app specifically recently and i was able to essentially incur a http request with
user supplied input in the path remotely from a different machine okay and uh this one specifically
came in through sockets web sockets but um it actually was able to you know i was able to supply
a path traversal and truncate the path and hit a completely different endpoint um and that ended up
having some really good impact and i was just kind of sitting there thinking about this and i i guess i just
sort of um assumed beforehand that this was more of a web-based vulnerability but pretty much anything
that interacts with http can be cspt um because uh traversals are such a key part of pathing in um
in most http environments so just think about that as well i i i know that sometimes as web hackers we
struggle to make the pivot to other types of hacking whether it be iot or desktop apps or buying
binaries or whatever um this is an attack that can be used fairly universally um because http is really
is really common even outside of um strictly web apps okay just a thought um and i'm also interested
in kind of thinking about other types of vulnerabilities that are more present outside of uh just the web
environment where we can sort of take those over so if you have any of those uh maybe drop them in the pod talk
channel in the critical thinking discord um yeah i think that there's definitely going to be more i'm
gonna i'm gonna keep uh spinning on that um okay another one that is really interesting another takeaway that i had
guys capital letters are really overpowered okay uh i was hacking with somebody i'm not gonna say who
who's going to do recently and we just found a ton of bypasses using capital letters okay i'll give you
an example of one of them this is this one is just uh one of like three that we use to find vulnerabilities
uh in the past couple months okay first uh we had a scenario where if a specific cookie was not present
that is pretty much always present uh when a request was issued to a specific endpoint it would result in a
vulnerability okay so how do we get this cookie not not issued well we could you know put it in a
credentialist iframe or whatever but we kind of needed access to the victim session as well right
so we've got this like catch-22 situation of okay how do i um send a request without just this one cookie
while keeping the other cookies was essentially what we needed to do and the way we ended up solving this
was by sending a request to the same path but with one character switch to a capital letter okay and what
that did was uh technically that is a different path the back end was processing it as the same path
but the browser was not sending the cookie to that path because the cookie was hard scoped
to a specific path that did not have that capital letter right so the path attribute for the cookie was
set to let's call it slash abc lowercase and when we sent the request to slash abc uppercase that cookie
would not be sent right so these uh cookies path definitions they're they're case sensitive and a lot
of times our paths that we're dealing with on http servers are not case sensitive um so just keep that in
mind obviously there's uh encoding tricks and stuff like that you could do but in this situation it was
actually as simple as uh lowercase and uppercase letters um there was as soon as some of these bugs
get resolved i'm going to come back on the pod and talk about them uh because there were some other
weird ones that we solved with uppercase uh letters so just be on the lookout for that i feel like it's
kind of like a uh you know simple method but it's it's very prevalent okay um two last takeaways both sort of
relate to um click jacking or getting a new tab open inside of your browser with top level navigation okay
so we're dealing with some client-side stuff here so um i ran into a situation recently where i needed
to be able to c-surf somebody to set a cookie and i needed to do this inside of a iframe because of the
constraints of the attack and then inside of that iframe there would be rendered a link and if the
user clicked that link and did a top level navigation with it it would result in a c-surf
um so essentially what i ended up doing here was uh performing a click jacking attack and the person
would need to control click one button on the screen and then their account would get taken over right
um because i could trigger the the login c-surf and then they click the button and then bad stuff happens
okay um so i hadn't really used that control click to open up a top level navigation from within an iframe
trick before uh so i thought that was a pretty interesting one that you guys might want to know about
um once again click jacking very impactful vulnerability type in my opinion uh if you do it
correctly okay note that last caveat if you do it correctly um very important so keep that technique in
mind and then last but not least i was just doing a little like brainstorming before this episode and i
was thinking like okay if i need to do a window.open i need to get a user gesture right that's the
technical term that you use to get a window open uh without a pop-up block in uh in modern browsers
and i was looking into what that is and i've just always kind of thought of that as a click
but it's not only a click you can also get this from a key down event which i think is a lot easier
to get in some scenarios i mean really this isn't a problem very much because you can always just
perceive um get the user to perceive it as like one of those accept cookies uh pop-ups and then you get a
free click whenever right really useful for pocs um but just keep that in mind as well that you can
also do a window open without a pop-up block from a key down event um the last thing that i wanted to
mention was whenever you do need this control click i realized that you can actually like make buttons
unclickable until you are holding the control key so that makes it a lot easier to like cerebrally
convince the victim that they need to control click something is uh you can actually hide ui elements
if the user's not currently holding down the control key um so just think that about that as well it's
much easier to program these things with ai nowadays so um it makes your poc a lot cleaner also definitely
want to cover it on the pod just popped into my brain i don't don't have time to do it today but the research
by lira on svg enhanced uh clickjacking is unfreaking believable you can make literally you know responsive
buttons via uh svg magic essentially um overlaid you know for clickjacking purposes right so the problem with
clickjacking is right there's an invisible iframe in front of it so when you click it it it you know
it doesn't actually do anything you don't see the ui you know button depress or anything like that
um but with these svg magic things that lira does uh you can actually make it happen so anyway i really
want to build a library out of that um i think that that is a really useful and mass applicable technique
um so anyway i'll link that research in the description um all right guys that's all i got for this week
i'm sorry we're gonna bring the heat coming coming forward the next couple weeks we've got a lot of
great interviews lined up and we've also got our first meta analysis episode which i'm excited to
present to you guys all right that's a wrap for this week peace and that's a wrap on this episode of
critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end y'all if you want more critical thinking
content uh or if you want to support the show head over to ctbb.show discord you can hop in the
community there's lots of great high-level hacking discussion happening there on top of the masterclasses
hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if you're a full-time hunter it's a great
time trust me all right i'll see you there